das motto am berg der berge unbezwungen
bis nach der mitte des neunzehnten
jahrhunderts 1865 wollen gleich zwei
seilschaften als erste oben sein
italienische bergsteiger gegen britische
[Musik]
das britische team gewinnt aber der
triumph wird zur tragödie
beim abstieg stoßen vier männer in den
tod
jetzt wollen nachfahren der
erstbesteiger herauswinken saß damals am
berg
forensische untersuchungen und
historische dokumente gäben aufschluss
das ist unerhört
war es ein unfall sabotage
wunderbare scarione
in zermatt treffen sich sieben
bergsteiger zu einer waghalsigen
expedition vier engländer ein franzose
und 22
ihr ziel ist das matterhorn in der
begehrte trophäe
der letzte unbesiegte viertausender der
alpen es ist der dreizehnte juli 1865
vier von ihnen werden den nächsten tag
nicht überleben
kopf der gruppe ist edward whymper ein
vom ehrgeiz getriebener brite aus
einfachen verhältnissen
ein wagemutiger bergsteiger der um jeden
preis nach oben will auch in der
gesellschaft seit wochen wartet ein paar
auf den günstigen augenblick
sieben mal hat er schon versucht das
matterhorn zu besteigen
siebenmal ist er gescheitert hier war
ein sehr ernster junger mann der sich
selbst ziemlich wichtig nahm ehrgeizig
und extrem gut in form
um sich fit zu halten lief er von einer
seite londons zu anderen und
schnurstracks aufs land hinaus
von beginn weg gut er nahm er
erstbesteigungen
zehn minuten pause er wurde in die alpen
geschickt nicht zum klettern sondern zum
arbeiten
der verleger langen wollte von ihm
zeichnungen als vorlagen für einen
illustrierten band so verdiente er sein
geld
webber ist journalist er beschreibt und
illustriert seine kletter abenteuer in
erfolgreichen büchern winter war richtig
scharf aufs matterhorn richtig scharf
das matterhorn war der letzte noch nicht
bestiegen die 4000er wollten
verschiedene engländer die lorbeeren
einer erstbesteigung holen und dafür
brauchten sie bergführer und die hellen
ali mit geld für das unbedingt weil er
macht die meisten bergführer von damals
wollten nichts von einer besteigung des
materials wissen zu schwierig zu
gefährlich ein unmögliches unterfangen
nicht so die beiden zimmer trat auch
walter vater und sohn
sie glauben an einer besteigung von
norden her peter traub walter vatter 45
ist ein führer der ersten generation
sein sohn auch peter ist 22 und
begleitet ihn als träger oben am gipfel
er ist nicht so steil gedachten
pioniere auch sie getrieben vom ehrgeiz
die bergsteiger von damals waren
pioniere
sie wussten nicht was in den bergen
erwartet es war wirklich aller indiana
jones
sie waren schon immer die wahren helden
das eigentlich auch referent charles
watson um seine jungen begleiter
dopplers händler lässt das motto keine
ruhe
doch das echo ist der sohn eines reichen
reeders aus london
ein erstklassiger sportler und athlet am
berg jedoch ein anfänger er wird beim
drama am matterhorn eine wichtige rolle
spielen
[Musik]
kanada ist da bloß urgroßneffe die
geschichte seines berühmten ahnen hat
ihn von klein auf beschäftigt
wenn er doch selbst ein erfahrener
abenteurer wanderte 2003 als erster ganz
alleine zum nordpol
meine entdeckungsreisen warum ich
polarforscher geworden es sind alles eng
zusammen mit den ereignissen am
matterhorn im jahre 1865 für pen hadow
ist die spurensuche auch eine frage der
ehre
seit 150 jahren liegt die matterhorn
katastrophe wie ein dunkler schatten
über der familie denn sein vorfahre
wurde für das unglück verantwortlich
gemacht ich hoffe beweisen zu können
dass er der sündenbock war aber nicht
schuld am unglück
er war der am wenigsten verantwortliche
des ganzen unternehmens
[Musik]
in salat angelangt zieht s pen hadow zum
schicksalsberg seines ahnen
er sieht ihn zum ersten mal
oh gott das ist eine wirklich
beachtliche berg sehr eindrucksvoll ist
ein überwältigender gipfel wie ein
rohdiamant
ich freue mich sehr ihn so zu sehen im
abendlicht jetzt verstehe ich warum die
menschen damals meinten könne nicht
bestätigt werden
er wirkt ziemlich aggressiv
das matterhorn die faszination einer
frau und die macht eines giganten
schrieb ein fairer lange zeit indes
interessierte sich niemand für die berge
auch nicht fürs material erst gegen ende
des achtzehnten jahrhunderts kommen
wissenschaftler in die alpen und
vermessen gletscher gipfel und gerade
später erklimmen vorwiegend britische
abenteurer gipfel um gipfel der berg
wird zur trophäe bergsteigen zum
leistungssport die briten behaupten
gerne sie hätten den alpinismus erfunden
da stimmt nicht schweizer und franzosen
bestiegen zuerst den blauen aber das hat
die fantasie der briten angeregt
es ist das zeitalter der großen
entdeckungen die gipfel der alpen gehöre
zu den letzten weißen flecken auf der
landkarte
hier finden pioniere wie wimper die
abenteuer die sie suchen
das war jetzt eine stunde geht voran
ich folge mit 25 jahren ist er bereits
der erfolgreichste bergsteiger seiner
zeit als mensch so unnahbar und bausch
gewesen sein
ein alpinist mit solchen zielen wie und
muss dann egoist zahlen wollte er diese
erreichen
ich meine es gibt kaum einen
egoistischen sport aus den alpinismus
ich denke schon dass seine erfolge
seinem charakter zuzuschreiben sind aber
auch seine misserfolge
heute ist vor allem die schweizer
nordseite des materials bekannt 1865
vermuteten die experten noch der berg
sei von der italienischen südseite
leichter zu besteigen laggenbecker nennt
man dort das motto am 10 juli 1865
wandert rimpar am südhang des
matterhorns ins dörfchen breul dem
heutigen charlene ja von dort aus will
er dass man down besteigen
schlechtes wetter zwingt ihn zu warten
das noch größere problem er ist alleine
[Musik]
wimmer hatte sich lose mit dem
erfahrenen italienischen bergführer und
warnt gar l verabredet doch carell sagt
ab
auch die anderen bergführer des dorfes
sind ausgebucht wenn du im park einen
findet wird ihn dir auf der
erstbesteigung nicht gelingen
er fürchtet ein konkurrent aus dem erb
ein klappt könnte ihm dann am matterhorn
zuvorkommen
am zwölften juli reißt der himmel
endlich auf
doch wimper hat noch immer keinen
bergführer gefunden
[Musik]
der ehrgeizige engländer spürt dass
irgend etwas im gange ist
gabriel ist ohne ihn unterwegs zum
gipfel der italiener habe ich den ruhm
der erstbesteigung ganz für sich
karel hinterhältige teufel
[Musik]
farrell wurde vom italienischen alpen
club eingespannt dieser wollte dass das
matterhorn von einer italienischen ecki
zuerst bestiegen werden
es war einer der letzten viertausender
und es sollte einen italienischen sieg
geben vermutlich auch um die einheit
italiens zu zelebrieren
die wenige jahre zuvor zustande kam
später wird er schreiben die italiener
waren mir zuvor gekommen
vielleicht gab es doch noch eine
möglichkeit sie auszumanövrieren er
plant das matterhorn von zermatt aus zu
besteigen
[Musik]
moment ich komme
niemand kann sagen wie die
erstbesteigung des materials verlaufen
wäre wenn nicht der zufall seine hand im
spiel gehabt hätte denn überraschend
trifft in diesem moment ein junger
britischer adliger in beuel ein lord
franziska kloos der 19 jährige ist mit
queen victoria verwandt er befindet sich
auf einer ausgedehnten alpen reise für
winter kommt wie gerufen denn dort wird
nämlich an
sie sind das gespräch mein klub bin ich
das und wer sind sie dabei das auto
umzusteigen
das haben sie einen träger einen führer
ja im sommer gut lassen sie uns keine
zeit verlieren
wir müssen die italiener schlagen sehr
gut gehen sie voran
in rekordzeit island atlas und wimpel
von beulen nach zermatt auf dem weg
liegt die hütte eines bergführers den
goldpreis von einer früheren tour her
kennt peter tork wald erleben dort mit
seinem 22 jährigen sohn die taub war das
sind arme bergbauern da kommen
wohlhabende bergsteiger gerade recht
peter traut balda hatte verschiedene
erstbegehungen gemacht er war einer der
besten seiner zeit
aus diesem grund ist es kein zufall dass
wir gerade für die erstbesteigung
auswählte
[Musik]
oft hat gesagt peter tragbar da sei
wegen des geldes in die berge gegangen
ich glaube das nicht es war für ihn eine
passion ein lebensziel den gipfel des
matterhorns als erster zu erreichen
es scheint dass wimpel gewisse zweifel
hatte ob balda die schwierigen
situationen gewachsen
[Musik]
viele zermatter führer mieden das
matterhorn wegen dessen fürchterliche
aura wollte den gipfel unbedingt vor
karin haben und darum bildet er dieses
attraktiven mit ludacris und den beiden
walder
es bleibt nicht viel zeit am abend geht
es runter nach zaubert von hier aus soll
das matterhorn am nächsten tag
angegangen werden der 45 jährige peter
tork walter soll die kletterpartie
anführen
sein sohn wird eilig vom träger zum
bergführer befördert
edward whymper hofft dass die italiener
noch zu schlagen sind
finanziert wird das unternehmen von lord
franziska kloos am abend treffen weitere
teams in zermatt ein
der wettstreit um die erstbesteigung
geht in die entscheidende phase wimper
und laut douglas logieren im hotel monte
rosa dort kommt es zu einer überraschung
am abend vor dem aufstieg team ihren sie
im hotel monte rosa und wer tauchten
plötzlich auf orts- und ist englands
bekanntester bergsteiger und rimpars
schärfster konkurrent zusammen mit
seinem jungen freund dessen erste saison
in den alpen
und michael krohn der berühmte führe
auch schamoni halt der kamerad von
wimpern der ursprünglich nicht mit
konnte weil er sich anderweitig
verpflichtet hatte auch sie wollten aufs
matterhorn
nach einer kurzen besprechung schlecht
wimper vor dass alle sieben gemeinsam
aufsteigen
es wäre fliegt gewähren in zwei
konkurrierenden sah schafften den herrn
liekam hochzuklettern
eben noch wollte jeder für sein land den
sieg erringen
nun versuchen sie es gemeinsam sie waren
noch nie zusammen zu werk gegangen
so etwas würde ich nie tun wenn zum
beispiel im himalaya eine erstbesteigung
mache bereite ich mich mit meinem
partner darauf vor
wir klettern zusammen damit wir uns
kennenlernen und verstehen die
seilschaft entstand aus der not heraus
die sieben zusammengewürfelten
teilnehmer waren konkurrenten und sie
ließen sich unter druck setzen
am nächsten morgen ist das wetter gut
die männer kommen schnell voran noch
besteht die chance die italiener zu
übertrumpfen
um die route der erstbesteiger
nachzuverfolgen stark benneteau der
urgroßneffe des erstbesteiger mit dem
schweizer bergführer und alpin
historiker hermann biener zum
sogenannten roll ist auf die stelle
liegt der nordwand des matterhorns
direkt gegenüber
wimpel und herzen waren eva wempe hatte
viele schwierige besteigungen absolviert
deutlich war gerade auf dem ober kabel
raum gewesen was nicht leicht war
aber das hätte aber vor allem zu hause
geklettert hatte was er trainiert aber
mit 18 oder 19 jahren sah er keine
gefahr
es ist unglaublich
er klettert erstmals richtig und das in
der nordwand des matterhorns wo zuvor
niemand gewesen ist
ich würde das nicht tun ja typisch
teenager ich sterben
später wird edward whymper schreiben
am ersten tag wollten wir noch keine
grosse höhe erreichen wichtigen geruhsam
auf am hörnli grad der direkt zum
matterhorn hochfährt wir waren
überrascht dass man an stellen die von
unten unzugänglich aussahen ganz
unbekümmert herum laufen konnte während
die gruppe um powell zügig fortschritte
macht lassen sich die italiener zeit
sie ahnen nichts von ihrer konkurrenz
vor dem aufstieg gönnen sie sich eine
ausgiebige rast
sie hatten einen maulesel dabei der mit
lebensmitteln beladen war
und da in italien magere zeiten
herrschten und die leute in den bergen
arme teufel waren haben sie vor dem
aufstieg vermutlich zuerst einmal alles
aufgegessen
auch auf der schweizer seite wird jetzt
halt gemacht
erst am nächsten morgen soll der gipfel
in angriff genommen werden durchs
fernglas kannst du die herrn die hälte
sehen 200 meter oberhalb gelte war ihr
lager
ein zelt soll die gruppe vor schlechtem
wetter schützen peter hauk walter
kümmert sich um die seile michael crow
und der junge taiwaner erkunden das
gelände grobe ein wilder schamoni er war
wohl der stärkste der seilschaft noch
einen zacken besser als der alte treiber
und so war auch ein haut sie kamen
zurück und sagten kein problem ist gar
nicht so schwierig wir hätten schon
heute hochklettern können
aber wenn du am fuß eines hangs stehst
sieht alles viel kürzer aus als es
wirklich ist
für die erstbesteigung hat man aus
england 3 seiler mitgebracht ein recht
dünnes aber damals völlig normales
standard sein zweites seil ist dicker
aber unhandlich und dient als ersatz das
dritte säule ist eine technische neuheit
und soll die gruppe besonders gut
sichern
erst vor kurzem wurde es spezielle für
den britischen erb ein klub entwickelt
[Musik]
diese spezialanfertigung ist aus drei
teilen hand zusammen geflochten ein
roter faden dient als erkennungszeichen
des clubs
das seil galt damals als besonders stark
im gegensatz zu schauen ist es den bau
dadurch soll es bei einem absturz nicht
so schnell reißen
[Musik]
am abend sind die sieben männer voller
zuversicht
wer etwas bringt ist die seilschaft eine
reine zweckgemeinschaft den erhofften
erfolg wird er sich jetzt teile müssen
es ist denkbar dass filme des hat mit
seiner neuen partnern zusammenarbeitet
weil sie bergführer hat er war ein
wirklich getriebener mann und äußerst
ehrgeizig selbst wenn er nicht die
führung innehatte so spielte er sich
gern als anführer auf er sah sich als
anführer von natur aus
[Musik]
vierzehnter juli 1865 der schicksalstag
kurz nach einbruch der dämmerung beginnt
der aufstieg über den hörnli grad
noch immer klettern die männer ohne
seile repower wird später schreiben die
weite des hangs offenbarte sich fast
1000 meter erstreckte er sich über uns
wie eine natürliche treppe
[Musik]
das matterhorn ist ein steiler berg der
auf allen seiten abfällt vom ersten
schritt an und hast du die ostwand zu
den linken und sogar echten die nordwand
und du bist meistens auf sehr
exponierten grad unterwegs
[Musik]
der berg versteht keinen spaß
jeder der sich diesen erklärt nicht
bereit ist und fähig den schnappte er
drei 1900 höhenmeter so hoch ist noch
niemand am bentley grad geklettert
die bergsteiger legen eine halbstündige
pause dann geht es zügig weiter denn
keiner weiß wie weit die italienischen
konkurrenten sind
die italiener um bergführer carell
kommen ebenfalls gut voran
[Musik]
auch wenn das team aus zermatt macht
weiter fortschritte auf etwa 4200 metern
über meer wird aus der eher schwieriger
[Musik]
bis zur schulter des herrn li graz war
alles ziemlich normal nicht ganz leicht
man kann auch tödlich verunglücken
aber es ist doch verhältnismäßig leicht
dann auf einmal erscheint der bergrücken
fast senkrecht laut wimper soll crowe
hier gesagt haben
jetzt beginnt etwas anderes
nun kommt das neue seil des erb ein club
zum einsatz
michelle crowe übernimmt die führung der
seilschaft
es wurde entschieden alle sieben anselm
saal zu binden um stärker zu sein falls
einer feld andererseits wenn drei oder
vier fallen kann man sie nicht halten
damals war der richtige umgang mit
seilen und nicht gelaufen
die arbeit so rimpar wurde schwierig
an einigen stellen gab es wenig halt
zwischen den fels schichten war schnee
so dass nur gelegentlich steine
hervortraten
weil ihnen die wand zu schnell fuhr kam
bescherten sie auf ich bin selbst schon
dort gewesen
man steht über einem enormen abgrund
alles fällt steil nach unten ab
es ist gigantisch das terrorist nicht
übermäßig schwer aber fels und eis sind
brüchig
man bewegt sich auf losen grund dort
gibt es wenig woran man sich festhalten
kann man wird sich bewusst dass ein
ausrutscher rathaus sein kann
die zeit drängt konkurrenzdenken treibt
das empathie immer höher
sie wollen vor den italienern oben sein
koste es was es wolle
sie wich nach rechts in die nordwand aus
weil sie hofften da würde es einfacher
sein aber das nordland ambiente hat
nichts mit dem hörnli krad zu tun
es ist ein schwieriger kletterei das war
etwas ganz anderes das spürten sie auch
sie hatten die größte mühe damit
[Musik]
in unerfahrensten im team war dies mit
sicherheit aus schwierigsten technisch
und psychologisch in diesem moment hätte
der eine oder andere erfahrene
bergsteiger sagen können wir sind in
gefahr wenn ein so unerfahrener junger
mann mit klettert das ist genug für
hätte jemand muss runter mit ihnen aber
eine solche diskussion fand nie statt
keiner denkt an eine umkehr alle hängen
an einem seil
[Musik]
dann plötzlich der gipfel ist zum
greifen nah der hahn wird unnahbarer
flach doch gemeinsam sind sie zu langsam
und trifft eine folgenschwere
entscheidung
[Musik]
man kann sich den erfahrenen ehrgeizigen
jungen winter vorstellen wie er sich
zurückgehalten fühlt alles ging ihm zu
langsam dann sieht er den gipfel seiner
träume und denkt ich will nicht denn
erwarten auf dem seil und rennt los um
als erste oben zusammen
[Musik]
auch michael crow macht sich frei und
heftet sich an die fersen
[Musik]
lemper hat er dieses ziel seit jahren im
kopf und da wollte er sich nicht nehmen
lassen
wenn du so nah am ziel bist hast du
sicher den gedanken jetzt ist es meint
jetzt will ich hoch es zeigt seinen
charakter aber auch seine verbissenheit
[Musik]
über die letzten meter und schreib
trümper
je höher wir stiegen um so größer wurde
unsere aufregung wie leicht konnten wir
noch im letzten augenblick von den
italienern geschlagen werden
[Musik]
um 13.40 erreichen twitter und co den
gipfel des matterhorns 4478 meter über
meer
si
die vorstellungen als erster oben zu
sein auf diesem angeblich zu
erreichbaren punkt das ist sehr
aufregend
[Musik]
was für eine erleichterung in italien um
karen haben es nicht geschafft
[Musik]
dann wird die erleichterung zum thema er
ruft kwl zu dass sie als erste wahl sind
[Musik]
und als cover gar nicht merkt wirft der
steine runter damit die italiener sie
sehen ich habe euch besiegt
es ist nicht das für baudichte kapitel
in der geschichte des britischen
alpinismus
[Musik]
zehn minuten später erreichen auch die
anderen den gipfel es ist ein triumph
nicht nur für wimper diesen rekord kann
dem team keiner mehr streitig machen
es ist ein rekord für die ewigkeit
[Musik]
die italiener sind geschlagen die
italiener am berg waren sehr enttäuscht
unten in brühl dachten ihre landsleute
sie hätten es geschafft
erst als sie zurückkamen wurde klar dass
die anderen erfolgreich gewesen waren
die sieger auf dem gipfel nehmen sich
eine stunde zeit um ihre triumph zu
genießen
ich glaube es schlugen zwei herzen
einerseits war er überglücklich dass er
den gipfel bestiegen hatte mit seinem
sohn
andererseits hatte er respekt
er wusste er hatte lloyd herrn seil die
bergsteigerische nicht gut waren
sie waren schlecht ausgerüstet er wusste
genau was auf sie zukommen würde genau
gewusst was da auf ihn dabei auch noch
sein sohn für den er verantwortung trug
das hat ihm sicher respekt eingeflößt
[Musik]
gegen 15 uhr beginnen credo hudson und
da bloß als erster mit dem abstieg will
bleibt zurück er will noch rasch eine
skizze anfertigen
winkler bleibt zurück um den glorreichen
moment zu genießen
die anderen gehen voraus michael crow
form und hinter ihm der junge hatte
damit kaum bei schwierigen abschnitten
helfen kann die abstieg ist
anspruchsvoller als der aufstieg
[Musik]
um den anschluss an die vierergruppe
nicht zu verlieren macht sich auch traut
walter senior auf
rimpars abstieg verzögert sich weiter
er schreibt die namen der erstbesteiger
nieder und versiegelt das papier in
einer flasche
dann folgen er und auch walter junior
allen anderen
[Musik]
jetzt sind alle sieben dem abstieg ganz
vorn die vierer seilschaft mit kroko
hudson und reuters der einzelne
absteigende kauf war der senior holt auf
[Musik]
[Applaus]
als er die vier erreicht teilt er sich
mit lotus zusammen
[Musik]
schließlich schließen auch im bau war
der junior auf die zwei säulen sich amt
auch walter senior an
nun sind wieder alle sieben angesagt
es geht vorwärts
[Musik]
es sind die seile die die männer in
einer schicksalsgemeinschaft aneinander
ketten werden
im leben wie im tod
[Musik]
man weiß doch wie furchterregend dieser
abschnitt ist
dennoch schlägt keiner vor einen der
wenigen felsvorsprünge als verankerung
für ein sicherungsseil zu verwenden
es gab diese diskussion aber dann ist
man weiter gegangen ohne eine
entscheidung zu treffen
dann kommt die stelle die schon beim
aufstieg sehr schwierig war dass sie zu
siebt an einem seil war das war ein
riesen nachteil dadurch wurde die
bewegung blockiert alleine das ist schon
tüten und dann das ist sicher dem jungen
helau passiert dann kommt die angst
man muss sich bewegen kann an einer
solchen stelle warten zu müssen
das ist psychologisch schrecklich willst
dich bewegen auch wenn es noch
schwieriger wird
aber wenn du nicht vorankommt kommt die
anspannung der körper kühlt mehr und
mehr aus du wirst steif ist nicht mehr
in der form die es braucht wissen sie
sie wollen daraus sie möchten nicht
warten
wenn sie merken es ist verdammt heikel
hier es ist der letzte ort nicht fordert
das strand schlecht
[Musik]
ergo ist jetzt auf hilfe angewiesen um
halt zu geben sicher dem crowe am fels
den tritt als das unglück passiert ist
dass kurz nach 15 uhr
[Musik]
bild kroh ceo charles watson und laut da
bloß stürzen ab sie sind die ersten
opfer des motors
man nahm
kakas
monat
sein
[Musik]
so etwas geht in den bergen ungleichheit
platz mehr
eben noch als durch starke fröhliche
männer männer die glauben berühmt zu
sein
das motorhome bestiegen haben und fünf
sekunden später sind sie tut einfach weg
der furchtbare blick in den entsetzten
gesichtern als sie abstürzten und
verschwinden und dann bleiben drei
zurück die wimpel erzählt fahren alle
wie gelähmt
eine halbe stunde lang bewegten sich
kaum sie standen am hang und zitterten
vor schreck
[Musik]
plötzlich sieht man was passieren kann
das geht durch mark und bein und man
wird verunsichert
die tag war da zitterten und meinten wie
kleine kinder
das ist absolut normal das war ein
totaler schock und wimper sagte
leonhardt weiter habe auch gezittert
auch ein engländer kann man es tätern
kommen sie waren alle drei komplett
fassungslos da gibt es nur eins ruhig
bleiben
[Musik]
crowe haxen und helau waren als man sie
auf dem gletscher fand mit dem manila
seil des erb rennclubs verbunden
laut franz ist aris wurde nie gefunden
die vier sind die ersten von bis heute
an die 600 opfer des matterhorns
wir sind hier am fuße der nordwand
ziemlich genau unter dem gipfel des
motors
die männer fielen über 1000 meter in die
tiefe
die gesamte nordwand hinunter am ende
sieht man diesen überhang von dort
fielen sie einige hundert meter im
freien fall
bevor sie hier aufschlugen
[Musik]
es ist grausam
mir geht nicht aus dem kopf wie es
ausgesehen haben muss als er hier auch
schon
man fand keine intakten rechen nur
körperteile
die männer konnten nur durch hemden
hosen oder gürtel identifiziert werden
ihre überreste viel über den
felsvorsprung klatschten in den schnee
ein grausiges ende für eine so
bemerkenswerte leistung
[Musik]
es bleibt unklar wie den überlebenden
der abstieg gelang
[Musik]
sie müssen den horror überwinden
für die nächsten 300 höhenmeter
benötigen sie sieben stunden
die folgende nacht verbringen sie auf
4100 meter im freien
später bekennt dass er in dieser nacht
um sein leben gezittert habe hauck
walter sohn wird sagen dass die ganze
nacht kein wort gesprochen worden sei
[Musik]
am nächsten tag erreichen die drei
überlebenden gegen mittag zaubert noch
können sie nicht was über sie
hereinbrechen wird erstens war wohl ein
großer empfangen darf dann rückte jedoch
rasch der unfall in den vordergrund man
fragte sich wer ist schuld wer hat was
falsch gemacht
es kam zu schuldzuweisungen vor allem
seitens von windsor gegenüber taub weil
der vater bald schon beginnt eine
erbitterte auseinandersetzung um die
wahrheit am berg es ist ein ungleicher
kampf peter hauk walter vermutlich nicht
einmal des schreibens mächtig die
publicity die der unfall auslöste mein
name is khan engländer ums leben das
waren laut die queen sagte man solle das
bergsteigen verblüht es sei schade das
adelige blut an die berge zu verlieren
die bilder des unglücks sommertraum
gehen um die welt
erst besteigung des matterhorns markiert
das ende des goldenen zeitalters des
bergsteigens
davor gab es kaum unfälle und nun dieses
schockierende fürchterliche unglück es
entsetzte die britische öffentlichkeit
dermaßen dass man es für notwendig hielt
in öffentlich zu machen und zu beweisen
dass keine fremde einwirkung keine
verschwörung im spiel war eine woche
nach dem unglück tag das
untersuchungsgericht in einem zimmer
hotel
es besteht aus juristischen laien der
richter ist ein hotelier wie kam es zu
dieser unglücklichen katastrophe
edward whymper beginnt seine schilderung
des unglücks mit dem aufbruch vom
zeltlager morgens um 3 uhr 40
von dort bis zur berg schulden sei der
aufstieg problemlos gewesen
erst auf über 4000 metern höhe habe der
bergführer michelle crowe alle
teilnehmer angesagt
danach habe dieser die führung der
seilschaft übernommen
um 13 uhr 40 habe man den gipfel
erreicht dort sei man eine stunde
geblieben
die stimmung sei da gewesen
[Musik]
für den abstieg so rehn weiter habe man
exakt dieselbe route gewählt wie beim
aufstieg
alle sieben seien mit seilen verbunden
gewesen
das seil zwischen lothar gries und vater
taub war da sei aber weniger dick
gewesen als die seile zwischen den
anderen mister haye hatte große probleme
mister crowe verhalf ihm zu einer stand
als er sich um warnte um selbst
abzusteigen
flitz mister haye aus sein sturz riss
mister komik und dieser wieder mester
hat und nach ihm lord david der kurze
moment dieses geschehens erlaubte es mir
und den beiden tag walder festen tritt
zu fassen so fest dass das seil zwischen
lord douglas und thalia vaters
[Musik]
nach seiner schilderung mit ein paar
entlassen das gericht hat keine weitere
fragen an ihn
peter traut balda befindet sich in einer
anderen lage als bergführer steht er in
der verantwortung wenn einer aus in
sorgfalt oder reile die berufs regeln
nicht beachtet jemanden zu tode kommen
ist kann man ihn wegen einer
fahrlässigen tötung verurteilt
das war damals nach dem gesetzbuch des
kantons wallis strafbar mit zwei jahren
gefängnis oder einer geldbuße
[Musik]
peter hauk war da sagt aus er habe am
morgen vor dem aufbruch darauf
hingewiesen dass zwei bergführer für
eine seilschaft dieser größe zu wenig
sein
lemper und harten arbeit geeignet sie
seien ebenbürtig daraufhin habe ihr
geschrieben das an seilen habe jeweils
bergführer grobe sorgt
beim abstieg sei dieser mit hoher atzen
und laut dollars vorausgegangen
das dicke ersatzteil dass crow auf sich
trug kam nie zum einsatz
lemper und sein sohn sei noch eine weile
auf dem gipfel geblieben
er sei dann alleine aufgebrochen
kurz vor der absturzstelle habe er doch
lausanne sei genommen
ich habe dafür ein dünneres seil benutzt
weil dort das seil ende zu kurz gewesen
sein um sich auch noch daran fest zu
binden
seiner meinung nach sei das sei jedoch
hinreichend stark gewesen sonst hätte er
es bereits vor der besteigung
zurückgewiesen
[Musik]
spürt und words
ungefähr 100 meter unterhalb des gipfels
sei otto ausgerutscht zum fest dazu
stehen habe ich mich gegen den fels
gekehrt da das seil zwischen wimper und
mir nicht gespannt war konnte ich es
gott sei dank um einen felsvorsprung
wickeln das gab mir die notwendige und
rettende festigkeit dekret gegangen
peter tag war da hatte auf alles eine
antwort
er sagte zunächst es habe einige
darunter gehabt die sehr fit gewesen
sein und mehrmals ähnliche situationen
erlebt hätten
wegen des saals zwischen peter hauk
walder und not da glas wurde hier ein
dünnes seil verwendet warum nahm der
bergführer ein dünnes er verteidigt sich
indem er sagt das vordere saal sei zu
kurz gewesen um sich auch noch daran
fest zu binden
kommt hinzu dieses dünne seil war damals
üblich damit war man noch kurze zeit
vorher zu berge
es war die pionierzeit man wusste noch
nicht genau welches sein richtig war
dann muss man wissen dass die reisenden
die seine selbst mitbrachten
denn die engländer mussten durch ihre
schifffahrts erfahrung mehr über seile
deshalb nahmen sie diese selber mit und
deshalb konnte man dem bergführer nicht
vorwerfen er habe das falsche seil
eingesetzt
ich bin fest davon überzeugt wenn das
seil zwischen und mir nicht gerissen
wäre dass ich mit für agro die herren
hätte retten können
die heimlichen das vatertag weil er
glaubte
er hätte sie halten können wäre das teil
nicht gerissen das ist unmöglich
wir haben an den bergführer kursen tests
gemacht die wucht die sich entwickelt
wenn leute fallen ist enorm
er meinte mit seiner aussage vor gericht
wahrscheinlich crowe halte sie von unten
er von oben
aber kuba auch gestürzt
so konnte nichts mehr machen im dorf
gilt talk walter nach dem unglück für
viele als held dank seiner christes
gegenwart konnte er drei menschenleben
retten
ich glaube schon dass peter tork
walderbach genug war dass er sich
umgeschaut hat wo er im notfall das heil
blockieren konnte
das macht ein bergführer automatisch er
ist immer wach und bereits das seil zu
blockieren sollte es zu einem rutscher
kaum ein bergführer vom format eines tag
war das hat das sicherlich gemacht
er war bereit um zu reagieren das
sicherte sich bereits auch weil der
vater hat jedoch auch kritiker im dorf
und neider
es gibt leute die behaupten die
einheimischen glaubten immer an die
unschuld von calder
aber es gibt auch andere für ihn war es
jedenfalls schwierig zumal war ja der
fahrer gegen die werkstatt
14 tote gab sagte man haben wir nicht
immer gesagt dass es gefährlich sein
wer darf damit bleibt bei der
berglandwirtschaft und zeit damit
zufrieden und so kam es dass die
stimmung allmählich gegen ihn kippte
[Musik]
vielleicht krebs peter traub walter
deshalb bei der zweiten befragung etwas
zurück und passt seine aussage
rimpars version bei der zweiten
vernehmung wird verhandelt warum es
unterschiede zwischen seinen und den
aussagen rimpars gab es ging vor allem
darum wer zuerst stürzte
und wer dann als nächster mitgerissen
wurde dabei steht immer die frage im
raum hätte man das verhindern können
hättet auch walter zusammen mit co die
anderen halten können
das war allerdings nach seiner variante
nicht möglich es gelang ihm das seil im
entscheidenden moment um den felsen zu
schwingen
dort konnte er es noch ein klemmen dann
hieß es
der rest wurde am ende von beiden
übereinstimmend fest gehalten zumindest
im verhör übereinstimmung zwischen wada
und rimpar geht es auch betreffend der
rolle von dr
dieser sei ein totaler anfänger am werk
gewesen das gericht entscheidet das
unglück sei ein tragischer unfall
gewesen ausgelöst durch das haus
ausrutscher am berg zu sagen es war
seine schuld ist lächerlich ihrer
eingeladen und wenn sie jemanden
einlagen sind sie für ihn verantwortlich
jeder hat ausnutzen können man muss
nicht unerfahren sein um am berg
auszurutschen
sie könnten auch sagen hatten ist schuld
weil er das sei nicht strafbar
es könnte sein das gros der ihm half für
einen augenblick die konzentration
verloren und das sie in halo deshalb
umstieß sie können nicht eine person
verantwortlich machen
bei einem unfall spielen immer
verschiedene faktoren eine rolle
ein händler der nachfahre von dacia
sandero ist mit dem entscheid des
walliser gerichts nie einverstanden
gewesen
in zermatt setzt er seine spurensuche
zusammen mit benedikt herren einem
nachfahren der beiden top weiter fort
im matterhorn museum ist das originale
sein dass beim unglück zum einsatz kam
ausgestellt
genauso wie eine kopie des spezial salz
des r31 klappt mit der roten markierung
faden
das original ist bis heute verschollen
kleinigkeiten wie hudsons gebetbuch gut
und rosenkranz von michael crow die
schuhe von lloyd dallas und besonders
aufschlussreich diejenigen die das hemd
trug wenn du diese schuhe vergleichst du
siehst du hier nägel unter der sauce
hallo schuhe sind nicht gerade zwei
total verschiedene paar schuhe
der eine ist ein richtiger fester
bergschuh mit dem anderen kann man am
sonntag zur messe gehen
stell dir vor du gehst mit solchen
schuhen auf eis das wörtlich solche
schuhe zu tragen
ich glaube sie waren in einem winter
wollte sofort los die italiener waren
schon auf dem weg deshalb haben sie die
ausrüstung nicht überprüft jemand hätte
sagen müssen mit diesen schulen stehst
du auf eis wie auf einem stück seife
was denkst du wird passieren
[Musik]
indes nicht alle glaubten an einen
tragischen unfall
neuer bilder und neue theorien erhalten
die geschichte am reden
wenn etwas einmal öffentlich geworden
ist hält es die presse fest und die
presse gibt sich nicht mit langweiligen
antworten zufrieden
sie braucht aufregenderes so beginnt man
über konspirative theorien zu sprechen
und gerüchte über geschnittene seile zu
verbreiten
das ist viel besser für die presse
bis nach österreich bringen die gerüchte
über den absturz vor
die wiener neue freie presse
veröffentlicht eine neue spektakuläre
theorie über das unglück im mittelpunkt
steht das hilfs und edward hopper
die zeitung schreibt dann als vatertag
walder die kräfte immer mehr versagten
riss das seil oder hatte ein messer das
hinterteil das rücken hervorgezogen wat
ass durchgeschnitten haben
es mag wahr sein dass der schnitt in
sile nur eine amputation war welche das
trennte was bereits dem tode verfallen
war und um diesen preis das rettete was
noch auf den füßen stand
jedenfalls aber bleibt die tat eine
furchtbare und ihre verantwortung vor
dem gewissen muss denke ich einen
menschen fast von singen bringen können
olympia ist in interlaken eingetroffen
leute die ihn von früher kennen wollen
ihn ganz verstört und wie geistig
verwildert gefunden haben
wenn das stimmt wenn es stimmt dass das
seil zerschnitten worden ist dann haben
wir es mit einer tötung zu tun
dann wurde es absichtlich gemacht im
damaligen walliser strafgesetzbuch gab
es da zwei bestimmungen nämlich mord das
war die vorsätzliche tötung oder der
markt wenn man die tat mitfuhr bedacht
gemacht hätte das waren schwerwiegende
delikte die mit lebenslängliche
freiheitsstrafe oder sogar mit der
todesstrafe bestraft werden konnten ist
das unglück sei geschnitten oder
gerissen
professor paul smith untersucht das
original aus dem matterhorn museum von
smith ist materialforscher an der eth
zürich
[Musik]
hier sieht man deutlich diese
schnittstelle
das sieht man unterschiedliche teil hier
sieht man deutlich dass das gestern ist
die ende von dem mikro phasen sind seien
gerecht teilweise und das ist nur
möglich wenn mit ein messer geschnitten
ist das sieht man ganz deutlich an die
art und weise wie die buchmacher aus für
mich ist das eindeutig
[Musik]
wer könnte das seil zerschnitten haben
meine interpretation ist das winter kaum
infrage kommt denn im verhör sagt auch
walter aus wimper sei weiter oben
gestanden und habe das ganze besser
gesehen
das macht für mich unwahrscheinlich dass
wimper in diesen steilen gelände runter
rennt und bei der schnelligkeit in der
alles passiert noch das seil durchtrennt
da hätte er auch noch das messer hervor
holen müssen da scheint mir sehr
unrealistisch haug war der sohn stand
laut den aussagen des vaters hinter
wimpern und konnte das unglück nicht
sehen wenn dann war es eher vatertag
walder der vielleicht zuerst das sein um
einen felsen bekommen konnte sich dann
dort festklammert dann aber spürt wie es
drückt und es sind vier leute unten
es ist prekär er merkt dass könnten
jederzeit alle mitgerissen werden und
dass er dann mit einem messer das sei
durchschneidet da scheint mir unter den
bekannten umständen am realistischsten
unter der umstand dass man weiß am
realistischsten sie
die bergführer von zermatt würden dass
man darauf wetten dass peter hauk walter
das seil nicht mit einem messer
durchschnitt
diese gewissheit vermag selbst das
zweifelsfrei zerschnittene unglücks
seien im museum nicht zu erschüttern
[Musik]
nein das ist totaler blödsinn was du
sagst das gibt es nicht das ist
unmöglich
da müsste einer bereits vor dem unfall
mit dem offenen sackmesser bereit
gewesen sei du kannst du nicht
vorstellen wie schnell so ein unfall
passiert man sieht es auch an den
verletzungen die peter teigware hatte
weil er das seil in den händen hielt da
hat er keine chance auch noch ein
sackmesser zu öffnen und drei bis vier
meter tiefer das seil zu zerschneiden
als beweisstück für einen seil schnitt
taugt es in der tat nur bedingt ob dies
das tatsächliche saarländer ist die
wahre schnittstelle bist nicht zu
beweisen
[Musik]
rimpar schreibt dazu er habe das
zerrissener seil gleich nach dem unglück
konfisziert in england machte er dieses
foto davon wie das seil von dort wieder
zurück nach zermatt ins museum gekommen
sein soll ist eine offene frage
alle lieben die geschichte vom salz
statt
doch wir sollten bei den fakten vier
männer hängen an einem seil dass er eine
bessere schnur war ein sehr dünnes sein
ich habe es im museum selbst rasieren
damit kann man ein schiebefenster
überziehen aber nicht vier bergsteiger
halten die abstürze
um festzustellen wie stark das seil war
das tauch walter verwendet hatte wird
ein original getreue nach geflochtenes
exemplar einigen tests unterzogen
weinexperte fädelt das sei in die test
apparatur 1
[Musik]
dann wird das gespannt
[Applaus]
das seil reißt schon bei einer belastung
von 300 kilogramm
der fall test zeigt dass das dünne seil
bei einer belastung von 85 kilo bereits
aus einer fallhöhe von nur 20 cm reist
dies beweist das seil beim absturz der
vier bergsteiger 1865 war so schwach
dass ericsson musste zum saal schnitt
ist es wohl nie gekommen
sogar das spezial seil das r-line klappt
wäre vermutlich unter der belastung der
abstürzenden körper an die listen
trotzdem hält sich das gerücht des
einschnitts hartnäckig und lastet auf
den überlebenden auch rimpar hat seine
kritiker und neider besonders unter den
ehrgeizigen bergsteiger des britischen
airline klappt denen er am berg manche
niederlage beschert hatte
[Musik]
man kann sich vorstellen dass wir durch
die verdächtigungen und das gerücht er
habe sogar das seil zerschnitten gereizt
war so marke zum schluss gekommen sein
es sei an der zeit mit seiner
einschätzung der taugt weiters an die
öffentlichkeit zu treten
sie hatten ihn nie speziell beeindruckt
er schrieb fünf jahre an seinem buch
scramble cindy ab und begann plötzlich
da seine kritik an den weiten tag war
das einzuflechten
das buch erscheint sechs jahre nach dem
unglück
darin wird die party im alten tag war
davor
er habe damals beim abstieg bewusst das
dünne seil gewählt so habe er sich
selbst schützen wollen
falls die ersten vier stürzen sollten er
begründet seinen sabotage vorwurf weiter
es bleibt die verdächtige tatsache dass
das gerissene saal das dünnste und
schwächste war
dies ist verdächtig weil keiner der vier
vordersten ein schwaches teilgenommen
hätte wo doch noch reichlich vom starken
seien vorhanden war
wenn tag war da aber vermutete dass ein
unfall passieren könnte so war es in
seinem interesse dass die bergsteiger
vor ihnen das schwache sein - das ist
eine verdammte gemeinheit von dem paar
eine absolut unfaire anschuldigung
damit hat er den guten ruf von paok
weiter kaputt gemacht es ist eine
unterstellung ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass peter hauk war da so
etwas überhaupt gedacht hat ich nehme
ein dünnes seil damit es reißt wenn ich
den gast nicht halten kann
[Musik]
der bruch zwischen winter und den beiden
tag war da muss in den dramatischen
stunden nach dem unglück passiert sein
[Musik]
rimpar wirft ihnen vollkommen mangel
eine haltung und brutalster
gefühllosigkeit vor wir kennen die
reaktion auf den absturz nur von wimpern
und wir wissen nicht ob das was er sagt
war ist gemäß ihm litten die talk walder
unter einem schrecklichen schlag
sie waren panisch wenn versagt sie
hätten geklagt was passiert jetzt mit
uns werden wir jetzt wo unsere
zahlmeister tot sind bezahlt eine
ziemlich schockierende bemerkung dann
reißen sie sich zusammen und wenn ich
mich recht erinnere geht wimper später
sogar ungesichert voraus unter schock
steigen sie am hörnli grad ab irgendwann
wird es dunkel und sie realisieren dass
sie es nicht mehr bis zum zeltlager
schaffen werden
sie halten an und verbringen die nacht
zitternd auf einem schmalen
felsvorsprung bevor sie morgens wieder
weiter können
[Musik]
beim eindunkeln so hätten die beiden top
ball dahin gedrängt bei mondschein
abzusteigen
danach hätten sie ihn genötigt sich
niederzulegen in einer so zudringlichen
und drohenden ort dass er um sein leben
aber fürchten müssen die leute waren
traumatisiert und wimpern mag vielleicht
das gefühl gehabt haben alle auswärtigen
sind tot und ich bin der einzige der es
noch nicht ist vermutlich hat er sich
dasselbe eingeredet
aber ich glaube nicht dass tag walter
vater und sohn in irgend etwas antun
wollten
wenn sie diese absicht gehabt hätten
hätten sie es 100 mal durchziehen können
wo im pass anschuldigungen treffen kauf
weil der fahrer schwer
er ist ohnehin angeschlagen seine frau
war schon vor dem unglück verstorben
zwei jahre nach dem unglück er trinkt
sein zweiter sohn josef im schwarzsee er
hatte weniger gäste das renomee war
beschädigt
und hinzu dass es für einen bergführer
immer sehr schwierig ist wenn ein unfall
passiert
das ist auch heute noch etwas das man
möglichst nicht erleben will
die abergläubigen im dorf sprechen schon
bald von der rache des berges
was fördert auch walter aber letztlich
vernichtet ist rimpars aussage war dass
er geistig verwirrt und als bergführer
nicht mehr zu gebrauchen
das war rufmord gegenüber peter tork
valdez hatte zur folge dass er gar keine
gäste mehr bekam und als bergführer
nicht mehr arbeiten konnte es belastete
ihn sehr
finanziell und psychisch
peter hauk walter band sich mit dem
dünnen hilfs oder halteseilen an lottes
weil er kein anderes zur hand hatte das
zweite das dicke ersatzteil druck
wahrscheinlich michael crow bis heute
ist allerdings nicht restlos geklärt
warum peter traub walter das dünne hilf
sein verwendete anstelle des neuen viel
leistungsfähigere und salz vom erb ein
klub jenes mit dem roten faden ihnen
[Musik]
doch jetzt gibt es neue indizien in der
weltberühmten pott library in oxford hat
pen hadow einige briefe und ein buch aus
dem jahre 1965 entdeckt thema das erste
unglück am matterhorn geschrieben von
ordnern den berühmten ski pionier und
mitglied des art einklappte
die schlüsselpassage handelt von einem
seil schnitt webos allerdings nicht beim
drohenden absturz sondern sehr viel
früher
kurz vor dem gipfel eine völlig neue
these das seil wurde tatsächlich
durchgeschnitten
was für ein schrecklicher mensch und gar
nicht falsch wenn diese geschichte
endlich einmal ans licht kommt
das buch liefert neue hinweise es geht
um den moment wo der matterhorn gipfel
in sicht kommt crowe und wimper waren so
aufgeregt dass sie sich vom seil los
machten
den berg hoch steigen dabei den knoten
lösen aus der schlinge schlüpfen und den
vordermann überholen
das ist ziemlich schwierig den populären
englischen romancier mason eingestanden
haben wie er sich aus dem seil löste
momper erzählte mason
wenn ich es mir recht überlege so habe
ich wohl das seil hinter mir
durchgeschnitten
damit sich leichter von kroos zum gipfel
eilen konnte wimper war derjenige der im
aufstieg das seil zerschnitt weil er als
erster auf dem gipfel seien wollte er
schnitt sich vom partie seil und rannte
los um sein ego zu befriedigen
deshalb nahm walter den vorwurf er habe
bewusst den saal genommen sehr über tag
war dann an das seil das ihm zur
verfügung stand im nachhinein betrachtet
war das natürlich ein fehler es war zu
schwach aber er hatte zu diesem
zeitpunkt keine andere option
nach wo im preis wahrscheinlich im seil
schnitt besteht das seil des erb ein
klub aus zwei teilstücken das eine stück
wird von den vorderen vier benutzt das
zweite teilstück von pau walter junior
wimper und auch walter senior die
verbindung zwischen den beiden gruppen
bildet das dünne seil wimper macht klare
aussagen in denen er seinen berg führung
vorwirft sie hätten aus unfähigkeit oder
sogar bewusst ein schwaches sei
verwendet um sich selbst bei einem
unfall nicht zu gefährden
und nun entdecken wir dass es wimper
selbst war der das seil auf dem weg nach
oben durchgeschnitten hat das ist
unerhört rimpar verschweigt einen
schnitt und bezichtigt stattdessen peter
hauk wahl der arglistigen verhaltens um
so die vermutung von seiner
mitverantwortung am unglück abzulenken
wimper schreibt einen weltbestseller
indem er sich als großen anführer und
bergsteiger darstellt das ist schäbig
insbesondere von einem der überlebt hat
und seine version der geschichte bringen
kann
[Musik]
peter traub walter fust zeitlebens mit
one pass anschuldigungen leben im dorf
soll er auf dieser angesprochen vor wut
handgreiflich geworden sein
er kam nie über im pass anschuldigungen
hinweg er war nachher ein gebrochener
mann
er wanderte nach nordamerika aus blieb
dort einige jahre wohl auch um etwas
distanz vom matterhorn zu bekommen kam
dann wieder zurück nach zermatt und
beteiligte sich am bau des hotel
schwarze
peter hauk war da wird mit 68 jahren
sterben
[Musik]
doch auch auf dem par liegt das unglück
am matterhorn wie ein fluch
[Musik]
zwar hat ihn der erfolg seiner bücher
finanziell unabhängig gemacht
aber der ersehnte aufstieg in die höhere
gesellschaft bleibt ihm verwehrt
[Musik]
im september 1911 wald männer in
chamonix im grandhotel gute dort
erleidet er mit 71 jahren einen
tödlichen schlag
[Musik]
ich glaube das unglück am matterhorn hat
ihn für den rest seines lebens
gezeichnet
jeder seiner aufenthalte in chamonix hat
etwas trauriges er stirbt er alleine so
wie er lange zeit allein gewesen ist
er hatte nach dem matterhorn keine waren
freundschaften ein mann der ganz
verbittert und allein in seinem zimmer
stirbt
[Musik]
bei seiner beisetzung kamen die leute
von chamonix und umgebung zum letzten
geleit
die bergführer begleiteten den
leichenwagen und erwiesen diesen großen
alpinisten die letzte ehre
und auch heute noch ist winter in
chamonix ein großer name des alpinismus
als die nachricht von seinem tod zermatt
erreicht sagen viele
jetzt hat sich das matterhorn auch an
ihm gerecht die cemat ersetzen nach dem
absturz auf ein paar als den großen
britischen helfen vielleicht aus kalkül
um die englischen gäste nicht
abzuschrecken und den aufkommenden
tourismus nicht zu gefährden
am hotel monte rosa erinnert eine
bronzetafel an seinen erfolg die talk
walter werden als erstbesteiger nicht
einmal erwähnt winter war für das dorf 1
siegen
es gab wegen des absturzes ein
unglaubliches medieninteresse vor allem
in england viele leute kamen nach
zermatt und wollten den berg sehen und
der stelle wo sich die tragödie ereignet
hatte es war der eigentliche startschuss
für den tourismus in der region zermatt
wurde so zum gewinner der tragödie von
die nachkommen alex perren rechts und
autor da hat es immer geärgert dass das
offizielle zeit stets nur als
erstbesteiger des matthäus feierte erst
90 jahre nach dem unglück wurde auf
drängen der tag war danach kommen an
ihrem wohnhaus eine tafel angebracht die
ihre leistung als begleiter von rimpar
würdigt die engländer waren immer die
pioniere trotzdem ist es nicht in
ordnung was man gemacht hat
auch heute noch heißt auf die frage wer
das matterhorn bestiegen hat der wind
über die taub war da spricht man bis
heute nicht
das tut einem weh die zermatter hätten
sagen können dass wir zusammen mit dem
tag war dann erfolgreich gewesen sei
deshalb würden wir nicht einen engländer
weniger oder einen engländer mehr haben
und niemand würde sich beleidigt fühlen
es gibt auch andere beispiele wenn auch
wesentlich später nehmen wir zur hillary
der mit sherpa tensing den mount everest
bestiegen und nachher zeitlebens ein
enger freund und großer förderer des
himalaya blieb das beispiel zeigt das
wäre auch ein anderes verhältnis möglich
gewesen
er gleicht sie
der letzte überlebende der katastrophe
peter hauk war der sohn setzt seine
karriere als bergführer fort er empfängt
weiterhin seine gäste meist ausländische
bergsteiger vor dem hotel monte rosa mit
ziel
[Musik]
beim anblick des hotels auf dem
schwarzsee marke sichern seines vaters
worte erinnert haben
schade überlebte wimper und nicht der
freundlichen ort dabei
die einheimischen geben ihm den
klingenden beinamen matterhorn peter
er nahm einen anderen weg bekam viele
gäste und wurde ein gefragter bergführer
das matterhorn bestiegen noch mehr als
125 x
benedikt perren zeigt uns die kleine
hütte im weiler bieler womacka horn
peter zurückgezogen seinen lebensabend
inmitten seiner großen kinder und enkel
jahr verbrachte
[Musik]
im märz 1923 stirbt er mit 80 jahren
eines natürlichen todes
die taucher wurden erst spät
rehabilitiert dass dies so lange
gedauert hat
daran haben auch sie ihren anteil
[Musik]
ich bin mittelgroßes und ich war oft als
kleiner junge bei meiner großmutter
weiler zumbeel muss im sommer wohnten
es wurde nie ein wort über die
erstbesteigung oder über das bergsteigen
gesprochen mein onkel war auch
bergführer
aber nein man sprach kein wort darüber
ich weiß nicht warum das ist ein rätsel
auch heute 150 jahre nach der
erstbesteigung zieht das matterhorn
alpinisten aus der ganzen welt magisch
an
das ist der ort wo es passiert ist genau
dort drüben am ende seiner spurensuche
möchte pen hadow an den ort wo sein
vorfahre in den tod stürzte zusammen mit
dem erfahrenen motoren führer benedikt
perren sucht er letzte klarheit als
hätte ausrutschte stand peter hauk
walder hier in dieser position
es gelang ihm das seil um diesen blog zu
finden
so konnte er es fixieren und das gewicht
halten
es ist sehr eindrücklich für mich weil
es eindeutig dieser fels ist für mich
sind diese kleinen details kurz vor dem
unfall wichtig es ist der einzige weit
und breit
[Musik]
wir sind hier nur einen schritt von dem
ort entfernt wo der tödliche unfall
passierte erst krohn
dann hätte dann herzen dann lothar klaas
stürzen auf dieser linie und versprochen
doch mal das wird ihre schreie er blickt
auf sieht einen körper fallen sichert
das seil über den block und weg sind sie
das war's so schnell geht das
[Musik]
sie waren eigentlich alle überfordert
außerhalb ihres erfahrungsbereich
natürlich haben sie alle ihr bestes war
sie wussten dass ihr leben daran hing
doch das beste war nicht gut genug
so ist das leben und der tod in den
bergen
und dann ist sie wieder da die frage die
sich die menschen schon vor 150 jahren
stellten
lohnt es sich für einen gipfel sein
leben zu riskieren
[Musik]
als pen hadow das grab seines
unglücklichen vorfahren besucht
verflüchtigt sich die sinnfrage
[Musik]
endlich treffen wir uns du hast 150
jahre darauf gewartet
vieles was ich in meinem leben getan
habe wurde von dir beeinflusst sein
ehrgeiz sein antrieb und ja deine
leistungen inspirierten mich durchs
leben
danke
[Musik]
war es ein unfall sabotage oder war es
mord auch neue indizien können dies mit
letzter sicherheit nicht klären
nur der berg kennt das geheimnis aber
der berg schweigt
[Musik]